well sports betting is gaining
popularity across the country as it
becomes legal in more states and it's
not with just men last year more women
started participating for the first time
a trend that also holds true right here
at home mary jane belliesa is live right
now at the west gate with how this trend
is growing tell us more about it mary
jane
well sheri good morning according to a
survey done by global wireless solutions
over 4.6 million women signed up for
sports betting apps in 2021 that's 115
increase year over year jay cornigay the
executive vice president at westgate's
super book operations says sports
betting is more popular than ever and as
it expands across the country we're
seeing that here in las vegas too at
westgate sportsbook cornugay says
they've seen more weapon place bets and
it's not just online or through a mobile
device but they're seeing more bets in
person as well
i think that's a big influence from
their partners whether it's their
boyfriends or or husbands uh and they
come in all shapes and sizes as well
that they
you know want to get into the fun and
they're realizing how fun sports betting
can be
and with sports betting off of your
mobile device or smartphone you can't
get more convenient than that and he
also adds both younger and older women
have shown an increased interest in
sportsbook apps and he expects those
numbers to continue to grow reporting
live from the west gate mary jane
villasa live local now